[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend den Sport den gibt später
wieder mit Katja streso ja einen schönen
guten Abend wir verschaffen uns jetzt
wieder einen
Überblick verhirrender Angriff russische
Raketen töten mehr als 50 Menschen in
einem Dorf in der
Ostukraine drohender karlschlag nach dem
geplatzten Verkauf des fortwerks in
saouis stehen tausende Jobs auf dem
Spiel und Meister der Einsamkeit der
norwegische Autor Jon fosse bekommt den
literaturn
Nobelpreis während ukraines Präsident
bei einem europagipfel um weitere
Unterstützung wirbt fliegen heute wieder
russische Raketen auf sein Land es ist
eine der verheerendsten Attacken in
jüngster Zeit bei dem Angriff wurden in
einem Dorf in der Region hakiv
mindestens 5 Menschen getötet Christop
desterell die Helfer in den Trümmern
immer wieder müssen sie Opfer bergen
immer höher geht die Zahl der Toten
schließlich in die dutzende und das in
einem Ort mit kaum über 300 Einwohnern
mittags kurz nach 1 ist es als
wahrscheinlich eine Rakete einschlägt
genau in dem Moment als sich die
Menschen gemeinsam mit einer Trauerfeier
von einem ihrer Mitbürger
verabschieden von jeder Familie von
jedem Hof war mindestens ein Mann oder
eine Frau bei der Zeremonie
jeder im Ort hat Angehörige verloren das
ist die besondere Tragödie grosser bei
kupjansk liegt im umkämpften Nordosten
wer hier wohnt hat bereits russische
Besatzung erlebt am Anfang des Krieges
dann die Befreiung und seitdem Beschuss
Angriffe immer wieder zu dem von heute
findet Präsident selenski klare Worte
auf telegram spricht er von einem
demonstrativ grausamen russischen
Verbrechen und ein Sprecher der
Ermittler fügt hinzu unsere Fachleute
untersuchen die Trümmer Informationen
über die Opfer und zur verwendeten Waffe
ein Verfahren ist eröffnet unter den
Toten ist auch ein sechsjähriges Mädchen
ob alle der Verletzten durchkommen
können die Ärzte noch nicht sagen
Anne Brühl ist regelmäßig für uns in der
Ukraine jetzt wieder seit einigen Tagen
Anne in was für einer Phase des Krieges
befinden wir uns
aktuell
allen hier ist klar dass dieser Krieg
noch lange dauern könnte und dass dem
Land ein harter Winter bevorsteht aber
ein Angriff heute der lässt die Menschen
auch hier inne halten Grossa ein kleiner
Ort 40 km von der Front entfernt an der
Straße nach kupjansk die auch mein Team
und ich sehr gut kennen kopjansk wo ja
die Russen versuchen seit Wochen
vorzustoßen ohne größere Erfolge und
auch
die militärischen Erfolge der Ukraine
die sind ja minimal ja es gibt diese
Angriffe auf die Krim aber im Süden da
wird um jeden Quadratkilometer gekämpft
während diese russische Angriffe auf
Ziele im im ganzen Land an Stärke
zunehmen jeden Tag jede Nacht den
Menschen hier wurde heute sehr deutlich
vor Augen geführt es kann jeden treffen
überall live aus der Ukraine Anne Brühl
für uns ja die Nachricht vom schweren
Angriff auf die Ukraine überchartet den
europagipfel an dem auch Präsident
selenski teilnimmt im spanischen Granada
beraten Sie über krisensicherheit und
Solidarität und diese europäische
politische Gemeinschaft die besteht aus
den 27 eumgliedern und 20 weiteren
europäischen Staaten darunter
Großbritannien die Türkei und die
Ukraine der Gipfel wurde als Reaktion
auf den russischen Angriffskrieg
geschaffen über das Treffen berichtet
Thomas
Walde volodimir selenski führt einen
doppelten Abwehrkampf gegen den
russischen Aggressor und gegen das
zweifelnde Unterstützer der US-Kongress
gelät Ungarn und die Slowakei wackeln
selenski die haupausforderung die wir
haben ist die Einheit in Europa zu
bewahren nicht nur in den Ländern der EU
sondern überall in
Europa der Gastgeber wollte versuchen
diese Einheit auf dem Gipfel
herzustellen Solidarität und Einheit und
Unterstützung nicht nur der europäischen
Regierungen sondern unsere
Gesellschaften ich denke dass alle
Europäer
voloden die Bundesregierung wird
ukraumind vor erst keine taurusmarsch
Flugkörper liefern stattdessen verwies
Bundeskanzler Scholz auf deutsche
Patriot Flugabwehrsysteme ich habe hier
dem ukrainischen Präsidenten gesagt dass
wir für die Wintermonate ein weiteres
System der Ukraine zur Verfügung stellen
werden das ist das was jetzt am
allermeisten notwendig ist Scholz
versprach ferner sich im Konflikt
zwischen Aserbaidschan und Armenien für
eine friedliche Lösung des Konflikts
einzusetzen die EU bot Armenien
humanitäre Hilfe und drückte ihre
Unterstützung aus für die territoriale
Integrität des Landes so steht der
Gipfel von Granada ganz im Zeichen
gleich mehrerer
Konflikte was ist los bei der AFD
parteichfin Weidel soll sich wegen
angeblicher bedrohungslager an einen
sicheren Ort begeben haben wurde dann
aber auf Mallorca gesehen und AFD
kochchef kupalla lag im Krankenhaus
seine Partei teilte mit es habe einen
Zitat tätlichen Übergriff bei einem
Wahlkampfauftritt ingolstatt gegeben
jetzt ermittelt die Staatsanwaltschaft
aber es gibt noch viele offene Fragen
dazu Christiane hübscher AFD parteichf
Tino kopaller gestern kurz vor Beginn
der Wahlkampfveranstaltung in Ingolstadt
gleich soll er eigentlich eine Rede
halten Minuten später sitzt er am Boden
braucht medizinische Hilfe ein
Rettungswagen bringt ihn ins Krankenhaus
dort wurde kropalla intensivmedizinisch
betreut heißt es aus der AFD für die
Partei ist die Sache nell klar besttigt
auf wurde hier an diesem einangriff
getätigt so gehen diese LE
mits kopalla habe einen Einstich am
Oberarm gespürt heißt es aus der AFD die
Polizei befragt vor Ort Zeugen sichtet
Bildmaterial kopaller habe eine Rötung
und Schwellung am Oberarm teilt die
Staatsanwaltschaft inglstadt mit dennoch
gebe es aktuell keinen Beweis für einen
tätlichen Angriff die
staatsanwaltschaftstad hat einfah wegen
Verdacht der Körperverletzung
eingeleitet gegen Unbekannt das heißt
dass wir im Augenblick nicht gegen
bestimmte Beschuldigte ermitteln und es
heißt aber auch dass wir im Augenblick
ermitteln ob überhaupt ein Angriff
stattgefunden hat Kalla hat das
Krankenhaus inzwischen verlassen die AFD
teilt heute nur schriftlich mit wir
bleiben bei einem tätlichen Übergriff
auch Kalas kchefin Alice Weidel soll
bedroht worden sein behauptet die AFD
seit Tagen ist unsere
Bundessprecherin schützten Raum wo
keiner weiß wo der ist weil Anschläge
auf ihr Haus geplant wurden allerdings
noch am 26 September tritt Weidel im
Bundestag vor die Kameras einen Auftritt
am Tag der Deutschen Einheit sagt sie ab
mit Verweis auf eine akute Bedrohung und
schickt nur eine Videobotschaft ich
würde nichts lieber tun als heute bei
euch zu sein aber ich kann es leider
nicht nun musste die Partei zugeben al
Weidel war zu der Zeit mit ihrer Familie
Mallorca
Landesregierung am Sonntag einen
Denkzettel jetzt zu einem anderen AFD
Politiker der Bundesgerichtshof hat
heute im Fall Jens Meer entschieden der
war Richter in Sachsen dann ein als
rechtsextrem eingestufter AFD
Bundestagsabgeordneter danach wollte er
wieder als Richter Arbeiten ein
sächsisches Gericht hat ihm das aber
verboten zurecht bestätigten jetzt die
Bundesrichter Samuel Kirsch und Christop
Schneider
berichten persönlich ist der nach
karlsruhr an den Bundesgerichtshof
gekommen Kläger Jens Meyer das heute
61-Jährige afdmglied war Richter am
Landgericht Dresden eher Meer 2017 in
den Bundestag gewählt wurde in dieser
Zeit ruhte sein Richteramt 2021 wurde er
nicht wieder in den Bundestag gewählt
wollte zurück in den Justizdienst doch
das sächsische Justizministerium
versetzte ihn in den ruhstand Begründung
Meer habe sich nicht unparteilich
Verhalten was das Dienstgericht in
Leipzig auch so sah nun bestätigt der
Bundesgerichtshof diese Auffassung so
warnte Meer auf Social Media unter
anderem vor mischvölkern bereiz die
vorstehenden vom Dienstgericht
festgestellten vom Antragsgegner
stammenden oder ihm zuzurechnenden
Äußerungen und
Verhaltensweisen tragen im Rahmen der
gebotenen gesamtabwegung den Schluss
dass das Vertrauen der Öffentlichkeit in
die Person und die Amtsführung des
Antragsgegners in hohe Maße
beeinträchtigt ist ein Urteil das weit
über den konkreten Einzelfall
hinausreicht Richter die als Abgeordnete
in die Politik gehen dürfen bei ihrem
politischen Wirken eine rote Linie nicht
überschreiten diese rote Linie liegt da
wo ein Richter mit seinen politischen
Äußerungen das Vertrauen der
Öffentlichkeit in die Unabhängigkeit der
Justiz schwer beeinträchtigt im Fall
Meer gehen die Richterinnen und Richter
davon aus dass er nicht mit beiden Füßen
auf dem Grundgesetz steht die
Ruhestandsversetzung deswegen
rechtmäßig in haben Unbekannte eine
Militärakademie aus der Luft angegriffen
dabei sollen mehr als 100 Menschen
getötet worden sein so
Regierungsangaben auf einem handyvo ist
der Appellplatz der Akademie nach dem
Anschlag zu sehen mit Sprengstoff
beladene Drohnen seien am Ende einer
Abschlussfeier für Offiziere
explodiert böse Überraschung für die
Belegschaft von Ford inouis der erhoffte
Verkauf des Werks an einen Großinvestor
ist vorerst geplatzt damit stehen im
Saarland jetzt rund 4400 Jobs auf dem
Spiel klar ist nur dass die
Autoproduktion im fortwerk in zwei
Jahren auslaufen soll die Suche nach
einem Neuanfang sie beginnt jetzt wieder
von vorn über den drohenden karlschlag
Susanne
Freitag großer Frust nach der
Betriebsversammlung sie hatten gehofft
endlich Klarheit über ihre Zukunft zu
bekommen jetzt geht die Hängepartie
weiter ich fühle mich hintergangen ne
weil wir haben alle geglaubt den
Investor wä da und jetzt ist er
abgesprungen und man fühlt sich von dem
unternehben wirklich
verarscht im stichklassen die schlechte
Nachricht kam per Videobotschaft leider
hat der Investor uns nun mitgeteilt dass
er das Projekt nicht weiter verfolgen
möchte wir arbeiten nun an einem
alternativen Plan wie bereits mitgeteilt
werden wir am Standort 1000 Ford Jobs
bewahren bzw neu schaffen aber es geht
um über 4000 Arbeitsplätze allein bei
Ford über 1000 bei den Zulieferern wer
der Investor ist bleibt geheim die
Landesregierung wollte mittinvestieren
es sollte ein Joint Venture geben 3000
Jobs sollten nahtlos überführt werden
Ford aber wollte wohl lieber
Arbeitsplätze abwickeln weil das
günstiger ist das wiederum schreckte den
Investor ab das zumindest berichtet der
Wirtschaftsminister er sieht fort in der
Pflicht zu glauben man käme aus der
Nummer hier billig raus das muss fort
akzeptieren dass wir das so nicht
zulassen werden wenn man nicht in der
Lage ist nachdem was hier alles jetzt
der Belegschaft in den 16 Monaten
zugemutet worden ist jetzt hier den
Geldsäckel ordentlich aufzumachen dann
knallt eben richtig dann hab man es
nicht besser verdient die
Landesregierung kündigte weitere
Gespräche an die Belegschaft berät
derweil ob es jetzt einen Arbeitskampf
geben
wird in Bayern und Hessen sind am
Sonntag Landtag Wahlen wir wollen nach
Hessen schauen wo die CDU von
Ministerpräsident rein die Umfragen klar
anführt wer also landet auf Platz 2
reheins Koalitionspartner die Grünen die
SPD oder die AFD bei den kleinen
Parteien geht's um die Frage wer kommt
rein bzw wer bleibt drin im hässischen
Landtag über den Wahlkampf entsportt
jetzt Stefan
Schlösser beste Stimmung bei Boris rin
seine CDU liegt in Umfragen klar vor nur
eine Ampelkoalition könnte ihm gefäh
die Bundesregierung dient als
abschreckendes Beispiel diese kakoponie
aus Berlin ist eine Zumutung sie ist
eine Zumutung für jeden und deswegen
sage ich ihnen zu wir wollen keine
schrillen Debatten führen sondern wir
wollen dieses Land führen sein grüner
Stellvertreter reist standesgemäß mit
dem E-Auto durchs Land alvasers Themen
Umweltbildung Transformation der
Wirtschaft und die Botschaft ich kann
Ministerpräsident weil ich ein Plan für
dieses Land habe und verbrenne ihn auch
in die Tat umzusetzen und auch natürlich
völlig klar ist ich werde auch am Montag
nach der Wahl noch da sein ein
Seitenhieb auf Nancy fäer die
bundesinnenministerin will im Fall einer
Niederlage lieber in Berlin bleiben
chaotischer Wahlkampf Umfrage Werte
schlecht bundesthemen wie
flüchtlingskrise im Mittelpunkt es läuft
nicht rund meine Einschätzung ist und
das zeigen ja die Umfragen alle dass 40
bis 50% je nach Umfrage noch gar nicht
entschieden sind das macht mir Hoffnung
ganz sicher im neuen Landtag vertreten
die AFD mit Spitzenkandidat Robert lambr
sie könnte sogar zweitstärkste Kraft
werden nur schließen alle anderen
Parteien eine Zusammenarbeit kategorisch
aus wir vertreten in unserem
Wahlprogramm in vielen Punkten ob es
wieder einstieg der Kernkraft ist ob es
Begrenzung der Masseneinwanderung ist ob
es Senkung der Grunderwerbsteuer ist den
Willen der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
hoffen muss die FDP der Wiedereinzug ins
Parlament keineswegs sicher Stefan NAS
arbeitet sich vor allem an den Grünen ab
fordert Verkehr gleichberechtigt auf
Straße Schiene und Radweg modernere
Schul Politik und weniger
Verbote wir haben eine klare Priorität
und eine Präferenz wir streben eine
Koalition mit der CDU und der SPD an die
sogenannte deutschlandkoalition die
Linke kämpft um ihre Existenz Janine
Wissler ist nach Berlin abgewandert Jan
schaluske und Elisabeth kuher bilden die
neue Doppelspitze soziale Gerechtigkeit
und Umverteilung von Reichtum bleiben
der Kern der Partei wir haben enorme
gesellschaftliche und politische
Verantwortung und Herausforderung hier
wieder in diesen Landtag einzuziehen und
den benachteil Menschen weiterhin eine
Stimme zu ermöglichen im Landtag in drei
Tagen wird
gewählt immer wieder zählte er zu den
Favoriten wenn es um den literaturn
Nobelpreis geht Jon fosse seit heute
gehört der norwegische Autor zu den
Preisträgern höher als zum Nobelpreis
kannst du nicht kommen danach geht es
nur noch bergab scherzte der 64-Jährige
heute fosse gilt als einer der
wichtigsten zeitgenössischen
europäischen Schriftsteller allein 40
Theaterstücke hat er
K stellt uns jetzt
vor saß am Steuer als der Anruf kam nun
steht er am heimischen Fjord und sammelt
sich ich war ja seit 2013 in der
Diskussion so konnte ich mich darauf
vorbereiten dass es passiert aber dann
sind
Jahre vergangen und es gab eine Menge
Gerede aber kein Preis deshalb dachte
ich auch das würde dieses Jahr wieder
nichtalsched Theaterstücke Romane
Gedichte fosses Werk wurde in mehr als
50 Sprachen übersetzt mit dem Preis
werde sein literarischer
Erfindungsreichtum ausgezeichnet heißt
es in der Begründung des
Nobelkomitees er konzentriert sich auf
Unsicherheit und Angst in der
menschlichen Gesellschaft auf die
grundsätzlichen Entscheidungen des
Lebens ganz einfache Dinge Gefühle und
Erfahrungen die universell
sind Schweigen auf der Bühne Liebe
Geburt Tod große Themen wenig Handlung
fosses wortkager melancholischer Stil
erklärt und belehrt
nicht manchmal denke ich dass ich nur
schreibe um der Stille oder dem nicht
Sagbaren eine Stimme zu verleihen
irgendwie und diese Stimme wird gehört J
fosse der Bauernsohn aus Westnorwegen
ist auf dem literarischen Olymp
angelangt
zum Olymp beim europäischen Fußball
heißt Champions League und für Borussia
Dortmund Katja will's nicht klappen
weiter sieglos weiter sieglos aber
immerhin konnten die Dortmunder dem AC
myin ein Unentschieden abbringen der BVB
war stets bemüht besser als im ersten
Spiel gegen Paris Saint-Germain doch am
Ende blieb es gegen den 19maligen
italienischen Meister beim
0:0 wenn nach einem grundsätzlich
attraktiven Spiel weder die eine
Mannschaft noch die andere glücklich ist
sieht das so aus nur ein Punkt zu wenig
nach dem ersten Spiel wo wir verloren
haben haben wir natürlich gewusst dass
wir unsere Heimspiele gewinnen müssen
gerade in der
taffengruppe ist uns heute nicht
gelungen es gibt durchaus sehenswerte
und auch gefährliche Aktionen wie den
Fallrückzieher von Julian Brand in der
36 minute aber für einen Treffer reicht
es nicht in der zweiten Halbzeit AC
Mailand mit den besseren Chancen wie
hier Theo ernandz aber auch dortmund
hätte ein entscheidendes Tor schießen
können beino gittens aus guter Position
ohne Glück nächster Gegner Newcastle das
gestern 4:1 gegen Paris Saint-Germain
gewannen und 1:3 lautet der Endstand
zwischen RB Leipzig und Manchester City
Leipzig in der Tabelle jetzt zweiter
hintertitelverteidiger Man City alle
Tore des Spieltags wie immer unter ZDF
heute oder in der ZDF heute
App die Vergabe der Fußball WM 2030 an
sechs Nationen auf drei Kontinenten hat
für heftige Kritik gesorgt auch der dfb-
Präsident Bernt Neuendorf hat die
Entscheidung als eine Zitat
ungewöhnliche Konstellation bezeichnet
und die Nachhaltigkeit hinterfragt das
verwundert denn auch er hatte gestern
für diese WM gestimmt der FIFA Kongress
hätte erst nächstes Jahr entscheiden
sollen doch Präsident Johnny Infantino
baut mit dem Votum im FIFA Rat gestern
schon für die WM 2034 vor klarer Favorit
da ist Saudi-Arabien denn sechs
Konkurrenten sind nun schon 2030 dran
die dreikontinente WM ist FIFA Marketing
und irgendwann spielen wir auf mon
Everest weilil weil wir dort ein
Fußballplatz hingezaubert kriegen und
und man das Vermarkten kann gespielt
wird 2030 in Uruguay Argentinien
Paraguay Spanien Portugal Marokko der
Begriff Weltmeisterschaft wird neu
definiert und das Wort Flugmeilen
sammeln auch danke schön Katja so ich
zeige Ihnen jetzt noch einen Vogel den
Vogel des Jahres 204 den kibitz ihn
findet man bei uns in feuchten Wiesen
Weideland und und sympfen leider aber
immer seltener ein markanter Kopfschmuck
sein Erkennungszeichen und ziemlich gut
getan der Nachwuchs aber der kibitz gilt
als stark gefährdet mit dem neuen
Ehrentitel Vogel des Jahres ist ihm
jetzt viel Aufmerksamkeit
sicher im Norden regnerisch im Süden
nach Nebel sonnig dass die Kurzfassung
die längere gleich im Wetter mit Katja
horneffer gerne empfehle ich ihn das
heute journal um 215 sich mit Marietta
Slomka das war's von uns schönen Dank
schönen Abend und bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend das kräftige hoch
Tora hier über dem westlichen Mittelmeer
schleust die Tiefs Olli das uns heute
den Regen brachte und das Tief Patrick
im Norden an sich vorbei das einzige
tief das ich sich wenig bewegt ist das
Tief quiron zusammen mit dem Hoch Tora
bringt es milde Temperaturen aus
Südwesteuropa heran heute Nacht fällt in
Norddeutschland Regen sonst ist es
stärker bewölkt und im Süden bildet sich
unter klarem Himmel dann auch mal Nebel
entsprechend unterschiedlich sind die
Nachttemperaturen sie sinken im Süden
auf 7 bis 2° unter den Regenwolken
bleibt es deutlich milder mit
zweistelligen 14 bis 10° die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei 16
bis 22° und auch morgen ziehen
Regenwolken über Norddeutschland sonst
ist es mal mehr mal weniger stark
bewölkt und in Süddeutschland zeigt sich
nach Nebel zum Teil auch strahlend die
Sonne am Samstag regnet es noch in
Norddeutschland und am Sonntag ziehen
diese Regenwolken weiter in die Mitte
danach wird es deutlich kälter in
Norddeutschland liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen dann nur noch bei 13°
im Südwesten gibt es nachnebel
Sonnenschein und bis zu 26° und dort
wird es am Montag sogar noch wärmer
guten Abend